I'm my tree and I play Davy my name is
Lee Rodriguez and I play Fabiola my name
is Ramona young and I play Eleanor I'm
pretty sure and where the cast of never
have I ever and we're gonna take a
BuzzFeed quiz to see which character we
are on the show first choose an
extracurricular activity to sign up for
ok got Orchestra drama club swim team a
lot of you would your politics club in
science club
I choose drama club I'm gonna pick
Orchestra cause realistically like in
school I was a part of jazz band and
concert grands like that wasn't the
first thing I ever signed up for I'm
gonna say science club usually yeah it's
cool you get to do experiments and stuff
during each class you're texting talking
to your friends taking notes shouting
out answers arriving late or asleep
talking to me that's that's easy I
always talk it up taking notes probably
pick a symbol of Davey's dad the garden
tennis the moped the coyote I was home
the moped made me cry that girl if you
could have one thing come true what
would be pass a hard class has a most
popular kid in school fall for you get
bullied in the school place get invited
to the coolest party get a cool car make
a varsity on a sports team that would
never happen to me I am athletic get a
cool car yeah I want a free cool car
yeah I'd want to be the lead in the
school play but like morally I want to
earn that which you have okay thanks
yeah no okay cool cuz they cool yeah
it's all get cool right what's the worst
thing you can imagine happening on your
first day of school forget your books at
home wardrobe malfunction spill your
lunch on yourself sent to the
principal's office picked last in gym
class or fall in the hallway take a pic
class and really yeah I would you a lot
that's really amazing
yes wow I just like if that happened I
would be like I understand it not well
no I
laughing like really like big bless you
last I have everybody like you waited to
hear your name and you never go you
don't link just hoping and pull me no
real flavors okay I'm just gonna pick
follow the holy series people are still
walking Willy stop for me if I'm on the
ground pick a slang word for mr. Shapiro
to use
liddie 100 shook it haha trust Sam
Savage I can like hear his voice on me
tail you know like reimagining with
dnews awkwardly I would say shook it oh
my god lady
I'm gonna go lady trust choose another
never have I ever character you got
Davies therapist Davies teacher baby's
mom John McEnroe Trent Eve
shreds Harrison Trent for reals
Trent your ideal friend will keep your
secrets challenge you tell you the truth
make you laugh go to parties with you or
friends who needs friends
I was very animated Thanks I will go
ahead a lunge you I'm gonna say tell you
the truth that's also true I will be
change it up and be like keep the old
secrets did you murder okay
finally choose a bigger deal with
character Archie Betty Jughead Veronica
Cheryl or Tom this is the hardest
question I actually met the guy that
played Archie one kid you know and then
he added me on Instagram and then
unfollowed me on Instagram so I'm gonna
go with Joe good hey Archie bye Betty Oh
big Sheryl
oh I got we got it bad men
I got a Paxton okay so cool you're
extremely competitive and love being
right even when you're wrong but when it
counts you're a great friend who looked
out for those you care about
oh I feel slightly better yeah you are
fun popular person who's always down for
a good time people are attracted to your
energy and big personality you're
protective of those you care about and
you have a huge heart so good that's so
true so much about through those you
care about you you know I think it's
interesting that we all got boy boy
characters none of us really thought I
was gonna get Davie but I thought I was
gonna get like Eleanor I'm not upset I'm
not sure we keep it liddie together
BAM shook it